you mentioned your father
what have you learned from your dad you
mentioned he was an important part of
your childhood
my dad is amazing i grew up
we didn't have a lot of money but it
doesn't mean if i'm born in a nice
country that always nice thing happen
you know um my dad for me is he's a big
role model
because i see him through to my life
facing a lot of adversity you know he uh
he stopped drinking when i was a
teenager he was an alcoholic
and i seen him struggle through that
you know and it was very very hard and
um
i've seen him work
like crazy hours like
come leave in the morning come home at
night burned out because of work
through almost all his life to the point
that it became
a slave of the system yes it became a
habit and a normal
way of living and it made me realize
that i've learned a lot through my
father
he taught me perseverance hard work you
know
when you face adversity you know to
never give up until you achieve it
but also he it taught me a lesson that
in a way that i don't want to be like
him even if he is happy
it's because i realize i don't think he
knows anything else
like he works through all his life
and i don't want to live to work i want
to work for it for
you know what i mean i want to decide
when i work you know i feel like like he
he lived to work instead of working for
a living
and perhaps it's because he did not have
choice
he he was the older of his family they
had they were nine kid
his dad my grandfather died when he was
young so he had to become
the father of the family and work to put
money on the table
so perhaps that what made him that way
and he became like
like a habit for him my dad taught me
uh when i was at school i was bullied at
school
he's the first one to initiate me to a
martial art he taught me kai ready
my dad my dad was a black belt in
kyokushin karate as well
very nice but because he was working too
much he didn't have time to teach me
and i needed self defense in order to
defend myself
i have a winning a great carrier and
mixed martial art but in the
in the schoolyard and that's so good my
next record my my my record is not very
good
when you're a kid and you're about
seven eight years old and you're facing
bullied
bullies that are
two to three years older than than
yourself
it's not the same thing than when you're
25 and the guy is 28 so there is a big
discrepancy in terms of
maturity so
my dad taught me introduced me to karate
danny i didn't he didn't have time to
teach me then he put me in a school
with an a teacher that said it was
jacques couture
and i grew up with a lot of anger
and uh there were two person that was
afraid growing up
it was my dad my dad was very severe
very strict with me
and i'm glad he was because i i could
have become very bad
i could have become chosen on a
different path
people see me as a nice guy and i'm
gonna i am a nice guy i try to be a good
role model
but i could easily have turned towards
our
around there there's darkness somewhere
in there yes they are a lot
and a lot of my friend have chosen that
pat and unfortunately
you know they they they are they they
are uh
they are not with me today even if
i'm from canada and canada seems like
the nicest country in the world
like i said it's even if you live in a
nice country not always nice thing it
depend
of the situation but that's what my dad
taught me
you know and he gave me that
to to because i i'm very good at
learning
by observing people and by observing him
i i see
the the struggle he had with alcoholism
and what he did
the the pain sometimes that even flick
to
to to us to my family but how he
turned he did that 180 degree
and i really admired that and i know it
was uh
very very hard for him and he did it you
know and for me uh
that's a great role model for me so
with your dad being an engine of
basically hard work and you finding
a balance of being able to work your ass
off
but also to be able to enjoy a piece of
chocolate
what is the perfect day in the life of
georgetown pierre look like so like
if you were to go through a day that's
very productive but also one that
makes you sit back and enjoy and say
that was a good day
what's that look like what are we
talking about when do you wake up
what do you eat what do you do it change
over the years
when i was younger i have a good day it
was like a good training session or you
know achieving
good thing in my training you know and
that's why i was very good at it because
when i i was obsessed you know i think
to be
good at something you need to become
obsessed and to me
performing in my training was everything
you know like
when i had a bad training session i
didn't tell
my training partner i was acting like a
like because of the my ego
i didn't you know i didn't tell nobody i
was like hey then i go in the locker
room
like man then then i'm playing the the
the the training in my mind you know i'm
saying okay i should have done this
should have done and it
hunt me it hunt me man it's a training
and it hunt me
until the next running session on when i
can redeem myself
that's how it is when we used to
train in in all together back in a day
in canada we had david luizo
we had patrick cote we had a
dennis
the best guy in canada they were
training with each other
before we were training in different
gyms but once a week
i made it and i would i contact
everybody that we all join for us
and we exchange ideas and we train with
each other
so a friendly i would say friendly
competition it was not
malicious but it was hard training you
know like not our goal is was to improve
you know but it wasn't
very competitive and when
that day you used to get out of the
training session with a bad performance
for me
he used to hunt me until the following
week
when i could give it back and and
perform better
with the guy that i had the most trouble
with that's how it was
and that's how you get better you know
but but
it was not a training where it it would
we were trying to do malicious thing to
one another you know what i mean
you need to be playful but playful but
competitive
that when i had a good training session
because aspiring was on a friday
i had the best weekend and what i was
going out with my friend drinking and
partying and have fun
that was that was my my
my my ideal day back in the day
today is strange you know my my my life
has changed
you know like um i
i am not the same person i used to be
when i went on my knees and begged the
ufc for a title shot
you know what i mean i am i'm wealthy
i'm healthy most importantly that's the
most important thing
and as and i'm going to tell you the
truth as good as my career was
man my private life man is a
million times better man i i
and and people ask me sometime they
always wonder they they try
to ask me and it's normal it's a lot of
people is curious and
the reporter and
in the sport of mixed martial art
we say we play basketball we play soccer
but
you don't play fighting so when you
expose your private life
we've seen that happen in the fight week
sometime conor mcgregor and khabib
your competitor knows that he cannot get
to you so what he will do he will try to
get to someone that you love
so may i never expose my my private life
i never post
instagram of my family of my stuff
that's the reason why because i mean i'm
in a business of
fighting and people know that they
cannot get to me
and i believe because i was bullied when
i was young
i didn't realize that when i was young
but it
helps me deal with the mental warfare
that i need that i had to face later on
in my life in mixed martial art because
it's a very egotistic sport
and there's a lot of a lot and a lot of
intimidation
and i was used to i've been used to this
thing when i was young so it does not
get to me
however the good way to get to me
go go go try to get to someone i i love
now man i'm gonna go crazy you know what
i mean
and i'm aware of that so in order to
protect myself
i always because i'm aware i'm i'm a
public person
so i try to always keep my surrounding
like in a private
yeah one of the ways that like your your
friend of mine
joe rogan has been an inspiration that
he he's got like
an incredible family and he for the most
part is starting to change recently
actually it's kind of interesting but
for the most part throughout his life he
kept it
pretty secret doesn't talk about it in
his comment he's a comedian comedians
talk about everything he doesn't really
talk about it
and there's something to that it like
preserves the magic
of this the silence of the private life
and i think it can affect the
the development of the kid if
the kid grew up being oh he's the son of
that guy instead of being his own person
you know what i mean
so so for me it's very important like
my parents are older it's fine but it
taught me a big
lesson when i'm with my friend at the
dinner or anything i talk
with person always share a thing but
when i'm talking
i'm aware of of the audience who i'm in
front
yeah and i mean but oftentimes those
people are just incredible it kind of
makes me sad
that uh you know there's a lot of people
that love you right and they're a lot of
really incredible people and you'll
never get to really know their story
that's right i mean i don't know for me
it makes me sad you see them like at
airports and stuff people will tell me
they listen to this podcast or something
like that
and they're i could tell they're
incredible people and it makes me it's
like a little goodbye
of a possible friend i don't know it
makes me sad it's right
it makes me it's lonely it's almost like
celebrity
is a lonely thing so the higher the
celebrity the more lonely you become
in some kind of way but of course you
have that little gem of a private life
where you can personally i believe every
relationship i
i like i don't like to use this term but
it's always a give and take relationship
you know
like you can gain something and the
person like
it could be something like not material
is materialistic like something oh he's
a good
confidant like you someone that can give
me good advice or or
it's a word i would say like extensional
like if a pilot as a co-pilot
is the co-pilot is extend as a
extensional relationship with him you
know so he knows if he gets sick or he
faint
he's there to make sure you know he's
there to help
and i think in every relation it's about
compatibility but it's about
extensionality
right in a way that if that person is
extensional
and sometimes we talk about about love
you know like
sometimes i think is is it is it a bs
word or not because
i myself sometimes look at i look at
myself in the mirror
and when i do s stupid thing sometimes i
love myself a lot and sometimes i don't
you know what i mean because i'm angry
at myself i've done
stupid thing so that means sometimes it
could love could be fluctuating
you know what i mean how about in
relationships sometimes you
people they say oh they love each other
but then when they divorce they go
oh i want the house and the dog and the
kids stay with me and
you know what i mean if you love if by
definition if you really love someone
and let's say you're an old man and you
love a woman and she decides to leave
you for a younger man if you really love
her
you're gonna help her pack and leave but
in our society sometimes
we we want to hone something to me love
includes
the missing somebody losing somebody the
anger at somebody it's all the passion
feelings towards somebody that's all
love like
i you know it's all part of the thing
it's the ups and downs
it's uh the sad thing is when the
feelings
towards the person the ups and downs go
away the forgetting
yeah that's that's the opposite of love
so the opposite of love isn't
hate the to me the opposite of love is
forgetting
and and that's that's a much bigger
that's like the depth of human
connection
that's how i see love so sometimes i try
to stay positive
and i've been asked how i try to
because i have the image of someone
who's positive but i go to my own demon
as well sometime
however we talk about love
when i was young
you know like like i didn't love
who i was at first that's how i love i
learned to kind of
love myself like i didn't and then when
i was going
to to bullying i was i believe i was
bullied because i didn't love
myself i i because i project a very bad
image
of what i think of myself i was
a kid that lacked a lot of confidence i
was looking down when i was walking
i shrugged my shoulder when someone was
talking to me i was avoiding
eye contact so i was a very easy target
for bullies and i think
bullies are like in predatory animal in
nature
they will hunt the the easier prey they
will don't they don't go the lion don't
go
for the the alpha bull they go for the
one who's hold or who's sick the weakest
one
and bullies are the same in society i
believe and i didn't like to be bullied
of course but i didn't like the
the person that i was but i found out
through martial art the respect
and my my coach was extraordinary to me
he taught me discipline and self
strength self strength
and i found out that i needed to in
order to love myself
i needed to change myself because i
didn't
when i looked at my son in the mirror i
didn't like what i saw
so i decided to become like
someone that i would love so
i tried to look people straight up
and and trying to showcase a more
confident image that i had and it was
hard in the beginning because i didn't
really believe in it but i
i faked it until kind of i make it
so when i was walking at school
more and more i was learning how to
become more confident and i was
like taking charge when the teacher was
asking questions i was
at first i was never answering it was
like this waiting always to be the last
then i was hey i i know what the answer
this is the answer
i got out of my comfort zone so to speak
and i wish i would tell you that i got
out of bullying
because a hollywood story i use martial
art to beat up all the bullies
but it's not how it happened to me it
happened because i
changed myself from the inside out
and i learned how to
because i didn't love myself in the
beginning i learn
how to become like someone that i love
and even now like i'm by no mean
perfect i do a lot of stupid thing
but i learn as a person and even i do
have something stupid i'm like
shoot i did something stupid i i at
least i can apologize to the person if i
realize and then
i know that i'm not the person i wasn't
the past
i'm the person that i am right now so i
can learn
and become that image of the person that
i love so
in in a way the reason i'm trying to be
positive and i and i
am able to stay positive sometime in
life
is because i'm always trying to
be like that person that i love yeah and
i think if you don't look yourself in
the mirror and don't
love yourself or don't see any positive
future for yourself
how can you change your environment if
you cannot change yourself you know what
i mean
you will never be happy if you're not
happy when you look at yourself in the
mirror
so change yourself first then change
your you know it's not the environment
you're gonna change for yourself
it's you have to go from the inside out
you know
this this i learned to martial art i
have a i had a coach who was incredible
used to drill these ideas in my head and
and give me confidence you know like
like this telling me all these
these beautiful things about myself and
how i
he's dead now unfortunately peace peace
to him but uh
he was incredible incredible he was very
very strict i was afraid of him i was
afraid of my dad and afraid of him
he couldn't teach nowadays like he used
to teach me because he would be in
probably in jail
you know but i'm glad he did it because
for that time being
that's what i needed it and i would
never have had that
the career i had and mixed martial art
without
this because i would i would never have
got out of my
comfort zone would have been impossible
and in order to improve in life
you need to get out of your comfort zone
it's hard it's very hard to do
and and strive to be the person that you
can love i i
that's that's that's beautifully put
george
you